I've keeps to its own timetable not ours
doesn't stop us from trying massive
chalice is out surprise and this half
tactical half strategy game spans many
generations insuring you'll be about 50
years into your game before realizing
you should have been playing it
differently the whole time so here are
some tips and tricks to make sure you
get a head start on this long journey
you start the game off immediately on
the battlefield so let's tackle the
basics of combat first its turn-based
and each of your characters have action
points to spend in movement attacks and
other actions like health potions think
XCOM when you move keep in the orange
area to ensure if you find a bad guy you
have another move to attack many of the
bad guys like these exploding type guys
are best taken down as soon as possible
and not next to you
if you right-click it'll short cut the
order so you don't have to confirm you
can also spin the camera with Q and E
and switch to your next arrow with tab
to save some time something important to
understand are positioning your melee
attacks
left-click a skill let's click the enemy
and before you confirm press the adjust
melee position button it's the dotted
pathing line with an x marks the spot on
it this is really useful for making sure
that your hero isn't standing right next
to a corruption patch or lining up a
sweet knock back attack on multiple
characters with your caber jack there
are some icons that show up on your
enemies health bars that can help you
the eyeball shows up if your hero can
see your enemy from a new location this
is important for your ranger to see if
you can take a shot there's also an
explosion icon that will show up
specifically for alchemists so you know
that they can throw their exploding
flask from the new location always take
the safe route when on the battlefield
to keep your damage to a minimum taking
any damage can actually take away
experience from your heroes so keep them
healthy even if it takes longer
hero experience is one of those
important aspects of massive chalice
Regents and partners train their kids
which are known as trainees in the game
it's basically any hero that's under 15
years of age the parents pass down some
of their experience every day so you
want to make sure that you're marrying
off some of the highest experienced
heroes that ensures that your next
generation comes out strong and ready to
fight you can build a crucible to help
out with the training as well you can
retire a high experienced hero in this
building they're known as standards and
they'll act is kind of like a third
parent for all the trainees in the
nation giving everyone a little bit of
experience every day this can really
help your curve so don't forget to do it
when it comes to making babies there's a
few things to consider recessive genes
can be tricky even though hero might
have mostly positive genetics they might
carry something negative when setting up
your first bloodline it's a good idea to
look at the brothers and sisters of that
hero if the siblings have a lot of
negative traits it's a good indication
that that hero might not be as great as
you thought they were there are some
really dangerous genetics to look out
for asthma will keep your character from
moving long distances and will hinder
you in the long run slow is another
terrible one it's basically like
permanent asthma heart disease is a
really bad one this reduces a hero's
lifespan by a significant margin giving
that hero less time to fight or retire
snuff these out in the beginning to keep
your family genetics strong personality
traits can be dangerous too you have
less control over these but our heroes
children are more likely to pick up the
personalities of their parents standards
from the crucible can't pass on any
genetic traits but they can pass on
personality traits so you might not want
to pick the guy who's got a thing for
whisky research is another important
aspect of strategy building out the map
is super important you know keeps
crucible saved right Guild's yadda yadda
but you won't be able to get any
tactical equipment if you're just
building the buildings so definitely
consider getting some items for your
heroes along the way like improved armor
certain armor actually becomes a
necessity when you get about a hundred
years in so think ahead
saij rights can really help out with
your research just be sure not to retire
too many heroes into the guild that's
right you don't actually have to have
three you need people to fight too
especially in the beginning so consider
just a few at start the map is
constructed in the form of an inner ring
and an outer ring the cadence always
attacks territories on the outer ring
first they can attack the inner ring
unless the outer territories fall so
fill up your buildings on the inner ring
first these will be protected from the
cadence at the start of the game until
things go south massive chalice trains
the characters and you through time and
experience you might be several hours in
before you realize your build is not
working don't be afraid to start over
with new tactics and builds until you
find a society that feels strong after
all no Empire lasts forever
and winter is coming but you got this
you